das riesige Fischsterben es wird zur
Katastrophe eine Katastrophe die der
Ostsee jetzt immer immer näher kommt von
der oder aus hat sich das große Sterben
längst immer weiter Richtung Norden
ausgebreitet und inzwischen bis ans
Stettiner Haff also ans Tor das zur
Ostsee führt tote Fische tausende
zehntausende und noch mehr aber warum
das weiß bis jetzt niemand immer noch
nicht
es ist die Ruhe vor dem Sturm einen
Sturm den man weder sieht noch hört eine
unsichtbare Gefahr das Gift der oder
jetzt droht auch der Ostsee und der
Ferieninsel Usedom die giftwelle aus
Polen
wir müssen mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen
die giftwelle aus Polens oder die
tausende Tote Fisch Kadaver Fluss
abwärts treibt wird jetzt am Stettiner
Haff erwartet der nordöstlichsten
festlandgemeinde Deutschlands ist das
tödliche Gift jetzt schon in der Ostsee
bis datos sind noch keine toten Fische
angeschwemmt worden aber wir müssen
damit rechnen dass in den nächsten
Stunden die ersten Kadaver auftauchen
und letztendlich damit auch die Welle
mit den verunreinigten Wasser
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern treffen wird
es gibt ja doch ernst zu nehmende
Hinweise dass es einen Chemieunfall in
Polen gegeben haben soll
Quecksilber soll nicht wie anfangs
angenommen Auslöser für das Fischsterben
sein in den untersuchten fischkadawern
sein bisher auch keine Schadstoffe
nachgewiesen worden so der
Umweltminister Mecklenburg-Vorpommerns
die polnische Regierung sucht nach den
Tätern vermutet dass riesige Mengen
chemische Abfälle in den Fluss gekippt
worden bis jetzt im Zentrum der
Ermittlung eine klopapierfabrik südlich
der Stadt Breslau Ende Juli so die
Vermutung könnten die Schadstoffe hier
bei einem Unfall ausgetreten sein
210.000 Euro Belohnung für denjenigen
der die Täter ans Messer liefert hat die
polnische Regierung ausgelobt er solle
laut Matteo schmorawiecki wegen
Umweltverbrechen angeklagt werden jetzt
fragt man sich haben die polnischen
Behörden die giftwelle in Staustufen
entlang der Oder zurückgehalten einen
Monat später wird jetzt die Gift oder in
die Ostsee münden bedeutet das auch den
Tod unserer heimischen Tierwelt
Becker die ist uns jetzt live
zugeschaltet in Stettin unsere
bild-reporterin
also es kommt der Ostsee immer näher was
muss man befürchten wie nah vor der
Ostsee ist es tatsächlich schon so dass
man massenhaft tote Fische finden kann
ja wir stehen jetzt hier an der Stelle
an der die oder eben ins Stettiner Haff
mündet und dann von da aus weiter in die
Ostsee man sieht hier die oder fließt
eben hier lang und läuft dann eben ins
Stettiner Haff und dann weiter ins
offene Meer und natürlich ist die Angst
eben groß dass das Gift dass ich eben
mit diesem Wasser fortbewegt und auch
hier bald ankommen wird für die gleichen
Szenen sorgen wird die wir jetzt auch
schon an anderen Teilen in an anderen
Stellen in Polen gesehen haben nämlich
hunderte tote Fische die da aus dem Meer
gefischt werden und eben diese
Auffangbecken die da teilweise
aufgestellt werden um die toten Fische
rauszufischen und aus dem Wasser zu
holen die helfen natürlich um zumindest
die toten Tiere aus dem Wasser zu holen
damit eben auch die toten Tiere nicht
noch weiter ins Meer schwimmen und dort
zum Beispiel von anderen Lebewesen
gefressen werden und sich das man geht
ja davon aus dass eventuell also eine
Theorie ist dass es eben das Chemikalien
in die oder gekippt wurden und die
würden sich dann natürlich auch in den
Körpern der Fische weiter auf andere
Lebewesen übertragen und das möchte man
natürlich vorbeugen aber das Gift das da
eben dem Wasser schwimmt oder ja dort
mitschwimmt dass es eben nicht
aufzuhalten durch diese Auffangbecken
und deswegen ist die Angst extrem groß
dass auch bald hier eben ja hunderte
tote Fische an Land gespült werden diese
eben auch weiter ins offene Meer treiben
gestern gab es hier in Stettin eine
Krisensitzung an der auch unsere
Umweltministerin Frau Lemke teilgenommen
hat und sie hat eben auch gesagt es ist
noch völlig
unklar wie was für extreme Ausmaße diese
Katastrophe eben nehmen wird also man
hat da wirklich noch keine ja keine
Einschätzung getroffen wie weit diese
Katastrophe reichen könnte
ja und bei dieser Krisensitzung wurde
eben jetzt besprochen wie man weiter
verfahren sollte es ist natürlich
wichtig sich jetzt damit
auseinanderzusetzen was sind die besten
Lösungen um weitere Probleme oder weiten
ja diese eben diese Krise in den Griff
zu bekommen und
heute im Laufe des Tages werden auch
noch weitere Wasserproben erwartet also
die Ergebnisse weiterer Proben die
genommen wurden und in Brandenburg
ausgewertet werden und da wird man
natürlich ganz genau hinschauen auf
diese Ergebnisse ganz genau hinschauen
klarer Marie Becker und trotzdem ist so
schwer zu verstehen weil das ja jetzt
schon eine Woche geht das mit dem Fisch
sterben diesem massenhaften Fischsterben
das hat ja nicht etwa die Verwaltung
bemerkt sondern erstmal Angler haben das
festgestellt so und dann hat man
Wasserproben entnommen und jetzt eine
Woche später weiß man immer noch nicht
warum es zu diesem sterben gekommen ist
also warum ist es so schwer wenn man
doch die toten Fische hat die
Wasserproben entnimmt warum kommt man
trotzdem diesen Massen Fischsterben
nicht ja nicht auf die Spur
ja das ist eine gute Frage und das ist
natürlich auch die extreme Kritik die
hier auch der polnischen Regierung
entgegen oder vorgeworfen wird denn es
hat enorm lange gedauert bis ja diese
Nachricht weiter getragen wurde auch an
die deutschen Behörden das hast du ganz
richtig gesagt Kai das war eben nicht
die polnische Regierung die das
öffentlich gemacht hat sondern Angler
haben sich gemeldet haben gesagt haben
darauf hingewiesen dass eben immer mehr
tote Fische an Land gespült werden und
erst dann ist man den Ursachen auf den
Grund gegangen oder tut es ja auch immer
noch und die polnische Regierung hat bei
diesem Krisentreffen oder nach dem
Krisen treffen auch noch mal ein
Statement abgegeben und es wurde gesagt
es wurden mehr als 150 Wasserproben
bereits entnommen und man hat da keinen
Grund feststellen können also was man
bis jetzt schon weiß ist dass aktuell
wohl in der oder ein erhöhter Salzgehalt
vorhanden ist der eventuell auch etwas
damit zu tun haben könnte aber die
genaue Ursache die steht eben noch nicht
[Musik]